now that apple's first m1 max have
proven to be a huge success
like i showed off in my one month review
of the m1 macbook pro
it's time to talk about how apple could
handle transitioning
the mac pro to apple silicon so in this
video i'm going to talk about a few
different things like how much
performance we should expect
how apple can shrink the size of the mac
pro chassis
how modular the new mac pro will remain
despite switching to apple silicon
and my thoughts on the pricing and
release date
so let's get right into it when apple
first announced that they were
transitioning their entire mac lineup to
their very
own apple silicon chips it was hard to
imagine how apple could pull that off
with the mac pro since it's meant for
extremely high performance
but very recently a report from
bloomberg claimed that apple is
currently working on various arm-based
chips with potentially up to 32
performance course now if we consider
that the current
m1 chip has four high performance cores
and it's pumping out extremely
impressive performance numbers
a 32 core m series chip is gonna be
mind-numbingly fast now i know that some
people were speculating that apple would
be packing in
multiple m-series chips into one machine
like for example four m1 chips on one
mac but that doesn't make any sense at
all the goal of apple silicon
is to reduce latency and increase
efficiency
as much as possible and apple did that
by packing everything from the cpu the
graphics
and even the memory onto a single chip
simply throwing in extra m1 chips would
ruin the whole point by introducing
extra latency so apple is much more
likely
to make larger and more powerful chips
with more cores instead
now on the other hand graphics
performance scales
better with more cores compared to
having a smaller amount of more powerful
cores
that's likely why apple is reported to
be working on in
128 core gpu
but before i talk about how apple can
pull that off
without messing with the unified
architecture i want to make a bold
statement
that many of you might not agree with i
personally believe
that the apple silicon mac pro will not
support
amd or nvidia graphics cards
let me repeat that you will not be able
to put a third-party card
into the apple silicon mac pro and
taking it even further
i personally don't think that any apple
silicon mac
will ever support egpus because
having an external gpu ruins the entire
point of apple silicon
and that is the unified architecture
like having everything built into one
soc
if you didn't already know the
thunderbolt 3 cable currently used for
egpus on
intel max are bandwidth limited and on
top of that
there is a massive amount of latency
that gets created
when the data has to travel to and from
the cpu
and the egpu for this reason we've seen
egpus with powerful graphics cards
drastically slow down the performance of
certain tasks
like video editing compared to just
using the macbook by itself
and that's why i think apple stopped
supporting egbus
because apple knew that it would
actually ruin the performance
of the unified architecture and if you
really think about it
if apple continued supporting egbus they
would essentially be admitting
that their own custom integrated gpus
that they hyped up
so much are not powerful enough for pro
users
and that's not the impression that apple
wants to make
however things on the mac pro are
different
because the mac pro requires much more
graphic scores
to satisfy the highest end professionals
so let's talk about that according to
that report that i mentioned from
bloomberg
apple is developing two gpus with 64
and 128 dedicated cores which sounds
insane the m1 chip currently packs eight
gpu cores
built into the soc so packing in
gpu cores into one chip would make the
main chip
the size of a pancake which i don't even
think is possible
due to die size restrictions and other
things like that that i don't fully
understand
so because of that apple literally has
to create
a dedicated graphics chip separate from
the main
soc just like we currently already have
on the 16-inch macbook pro but because
this is the mac
pro that we're talking about apple has
to figure out some way
to make it at least somewhat modular
without sacrificing the whole
unified architecture that makes the m1
max
so good so here's what i think apple is
gonna do
you're gonna have a choice for your main
soc which will pack everything from a
cpu
an integrated gpu and integrated unified
memory
and all of the other components we
currently have in the m1 chip
the base model will likely come with a
12 or 16 core m
series chip with the option to upgrade
to a mid-range
20 core chip and finally a high-end
32 core chip and all of them will come
with a good amount of integrated
graphics cores
and unified memory as well but
thankfully there's a good chance that
apple will keep the user replaceable ram
slots
available for those who really need
massive amounts of ram
but the whole mac os system and simple
tasks
will continue to run on the unified
memory to keep things feeling very
snappy
apple will also continue selling their
mac pro ssd kits as well
keeping things modular and you'll still
be able to plug in
audio cards and whatever else but just
not
third-party graphics cards so on that
subject let's get into how apple could
handle
the dedicated graphics card situation i
personally think that on top of the main
soc
you'll have the option to add in one or
two
dedicated apple graphics cards that you
can plug in to the main board now
because these dedicated cards aren't
built into the soc
therefore being less efficient apple
could potentially come out with some
sort of high bandwidth
proprietary connector that utilizes pci
express 4.0
because yes apple has already confirmed
that even the m1 chip
supports pcie 4. this connector
obviously won't be as
optimized and latency free as having the
graphics integrated into the soc
but the dedicated graphics chips will be
used for tasks
that require a ton of raw graphics
rendering power
and the nice thing for apple is that
since they'll no longer support amd
graphics cards
they don't have to use the standardized
pci express slots
they can use whatever connector they
want and position it in
any way they'd like to and on top of
that they can now get rid of those extra
power plugs on the motherboard
that are meant for powering third-party
graphics cards
this means that they'll be able to
easily shrink down the mac pro's chassis
to be at least 33 percent smaller
because if you think about it they no
longer need
a huge 1400 watt power supply
because the new arm chips are extremely
efficient
and by the time this mac pro gets
released in 2022
the new chips will be on tsmc's three
nanometer process
which by the way apple has already
claimed
so these new chips are not only going to
be extremely fast
like industry braking fast but they're
also going to be
incredibly efficient as well because of
that the mac pro will no longer need
that huge of a heat sink for the cpu or
those massive fans they can shrink all
of that down
and still be completely fine in terms of
cooling
taking it even further the mac pro
doesn't need
such a massive motherboard because their
armbase designs are modern
and optimized the current mac pro has 8
pci express expansion slots
and that's because their mpx graphics
modules are
massive taking up double the space
of a standard graphics card apple's
dedicated custom graphics cards
will most likely be able to fit in one
slot
just like apple's afterburner card which
i believe
apple will also redesign to make it fit
in the new smaller chassis
so therefore apple will no longer need 8
pci slots
maybe 4 or 6 tops will be just fine
allowing apple to shrink down the mac
pro even more however i don't think that
apple's going to make it two times
smaller
like some people are currently
speculating because i think it's just
gonna look funny
and it's gonna cause it to lose the
powerful presence that it currently has
so i'm thinking the apple will keep the
dimensional ratio the same
but make it maybe around 33 percent
smaller
now you might be thinking that
everything being locked down
would really piss off a lot of apple's
professional customers
but i think the performance is going to
be so enticing
that many of them won't care and in the
worst case scenario
i'm sure that apple will continue
selling intel versions of the mac pro
for at least a year or two after the
release of the apple
silicon mac pro but in my opinion that
will be a bad choice for most people
because the current entry level m1
macbook pro
is already faster than the 12 core
mac pro for things like xcode
programming
so just imagine how fast an apple
silicon mac pro
with 32 cpu cores and 128 gpu cores will
be
while not taking nearly as much power
and staying
much cooler so let me finally finish off
with a few details that i can speculate
on
in terms of the pricing and the release
date of the apple silicon mac pro
apple did say that there will be a two
year transition
and based on how well the m1 max are
performing right now
it's obvious that apple can finish the
transition
sooner if they really wanted to however
i think apple
already knew that the transition would
be this smooth
so that two-year transition isn't a
guess
it's a release timeline so i think that
it makes the most sense for the mac pro
to get released in 2022
because this will allow apple to space
out their lower end mac releases
like the 16-inch macbook pro and the
high-end imac
before they finally release the mac pro
and if you're wondering when in 2022
i'm gonna go ahead and say december
because of two very good reasons
for reason number one i personally
believe that apple wants the mac pro's
chips
to be running on tsmc's three nanometer
chip architecture
since apple has already claimed all of
the three nanometer supply
two full years in advance this basically
means that the mac pro will only be able
to get released
after apple reveals the three nanometer
a15 chips
for their iphones which usually happens
in september
and for reason number two the last two
generations of the mac pro
and the imac pro were all released in
december which is the perfect time for
companies to spend
the rest of their tech budgets right
before the tax season ends
so they can lower their tax bill and as
far as the price
i have a very good feeling that the
apple silicon mac pro could easily start
at a less expensive
three to four thousand dollars and
that's because
the chassis will be smaller apple will
be saving money on
each chip they don't have to buy from
intel and amd
and finally apple won't have to pack
overkill components
like the 1400 watt power supply and the
massive cooling system
into each and every mac pro because they
know
that people will not be able to toss in
a couple of power hungry
rx 6900 xt's apple will have full
control
over every aspect of the mac pro so they
only
need as much power and cooling as their
efficient
three nanometer chips will need which in
turn
will bring down the base price of the
apple silicon
mac pro so there you guys go hopefully
you enjoyed this video and if you
disagree with any of my speculations
comment down below and definitely check
out my m1 macbook pro review right over
there
thank you for watching and we'll see you
in the next video
[Music]